[Music]
here's your money briefing for Wednesday
May 3rd I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
companies offering significant pay races
to lower new hires was a Hallmark of the
ultra competitive labor market last year
Wall Street Journal personal finance
reporter Julia Carpenter joins me to
discuss why those red hot offers are
cooling off in 2023 so Julia how much
have those pay bumps offered by
companies to encourage workers to make a
move shrunk this year so according to
wage tracking data from the Federal
Reserve Bank of Atlanta the typical job
switcher earned an 8.4 percent raise in
August 2022 and in March of this year
wage growth for job switchers had fallen
around 7.3 percent oh that's a sizable
jump why is that number come down so
part of it is that the so-called quits
rate which measures how many people
voluntarily leave employment has fallen
to 2.6 percent in February so that's
down from that 2021 High the high of
three percent that's data from the
Bureau of Labor Statistics yeah we saw
Just A Rush of workers changing jobs
back and forth pretty much throughout
2021 and most of 2022. I think a lot of
people remember all the headlines about
the great resignation and they remember
seeing in job listings or talking with
friends that employers were paying these
huge premiums in an attempt to lure new
talent and that's not happening as much
anymore we're seeing the power shift
back to the employer now the labor
Department's monthly jobs report shows
that employers continue to hire workers
at a strong Pace they added 236 000 jobs
in March alone how is that affecting
this equation that's again speaking to
this lessened pressure that employers
are feeling they felt this huge pressure
previously to keep new talent to recruit
new talent and that pressure lessened
now they're not willing to pay those
High premiums and workers are also
realizing that they don't have the
leverage they once had but is there more
to this than just companies dangling
lower salary bumps people probably feel
this in their own wallets but inflation
is sort of eating away at many pay
raises it's not going as far as it once
did we're in an unsettled market right
now with fears of a potential recession
so people don't want to trade off that
disruption of changing jobs or doing it
more than once for you know a pay raise
that may or may not be there and I think
a lot of people are saying this that pay
raise that is there may not be going as
far as it once did since inflation is
Raising costs on everything from gas to
groceries so what does this mean for
people who didn't switch jobs in 2021
and 2022 last year workers who remained
at their job got an average 5.6 pay
increase and that was significantly
lower than the salary increases we saw
for those who switch jobs but then this
year that race for people who stayed put
has bumped up it's now around like 5.9
percent in terms of pay I also look a
little bit of a reward for staying put
definitely a little bit of a better
situation than the year before yeah now
you spoke with people who considered
leaving their jobs when those higher
salary offers were on the table but they
didn't but what do they tell you about
that I talked to some people who said
that they got the timing wrong that if
they had been in a place where they
could have switched jobs or if the offer
had been more attractive for other
reasons they would have been able to
take advantage of that premium and
salary but others say they value the job
stability that especially now when
there's so many fears of a recession
fears of layoffs people value staying
put and knowing the familiar things
about their current job you know you
mentioned job stability a moment ago how
important is that to people as they're
sitting at their jobs and just thinking
about the effect of the broader economy
on their lives I talked to a lot of
people who are feeling sort of jittery
right now they're hearing all this news
of layoffs in particular Industries or
they're worried about what could happen
with the effects of a potential
recession so changing jobs right now is
not top of mind for them that's Julia
Carpenter from the wsj personal finance
team and that's your money briefing I'm
J.R Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
foreign